hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday February 1st 2016 what's
going on there you go the first month of
the year it's out of the way an old
Billy boos bag has been doing really
well
all right last time I got hammered last
time I got hammered was the last date
virzi was out here visiting me whatever
[ __ ] day that was it was like the
second or third of January and I didn't
drink for the rest of the month other
than the fact I had eight beers left
over from the Rose Bowl so I just drank
like one a day for eight straight days
always wanting a second forget about a
third in a ninth beer but I just I just
had one that was it self it's not bad
for me
you know I went like three weeks without
drinking than eight straight days I only
had one beer and then yesterday I didn't
have any beer in the fridge I might have
a Guinness left but I didn't drink it so
you know we were out here it was Sunday
it was [ __ ] raining to beat the band
is that the [ __ ] expression to play
the band I even know what it was [ __ ]
pouring out here for like legitimately
the almost the entire day which is great
we could probably use about 90 more
those days but that was good that that
was happening so I just [ __ ] stayed
home didn't do [ __ ]
last time I did Joe Rogan's podcast he
gave me some elk meat that he had he
[ __ ] killed an elk he murdered it
premeditated the man got in his car said
I'm gonna kill a [ __ ] out but he
didn't know which one so we can only get
him on second-degree murder and I became
an accessory to the murder when I agreed
to take some of the carcass off his
heads now he just gave me these two like
giant like softball sized things of elk
and they've been sitting in my freezer
so I heard the meats really lean and
that it could be a little gamy so I just
looked up some recipes and there was
something there for like
Elle Chile and so I I made that
yesterday and and it was [ __ ]
delicious but of course the lovely Nia
goes out there and be like is this done
this doesn't look done this doesn't I
guess I'm just not used to Chile with
this like consistency this looks more
like a stew because it wasn't any tomato
paste in the recipe it was still
delicious it was definitely a little
more watery so she had to go out and go
[ __ ] with the whole thing and I'm eating
the one that I made and I'm enjoying it
she just keeps in like the other room
just kept going like just like will you
shut up it's fine [ __ ] time I go out
in the kitchen she [ __ ] nitpicks
whatever the hell it is that I'm making
it's [ __ ] unbelievable she makes
something I eat it's good go out there
and go to the [ __ ] spice rack you
know it's it's it's it's it's rude it's
rude so we got into it you know as we
always do right get into it a little bit
then she laughs tell me to go [ __ ]
myself and then she gave me her version
with the tomato paste and you know I say
so yeah I see what you're saying I like
it
you know that guess what I really felt I
felt the first one tasted better
she thickened it all up with this
[ __ ] tomato paste and they made it
like sweeter and you know did it to the
whole [ __ ] pot so you know we had a
giant pot of it cells like well I can
handle what the [ __ ] she did to it if
it's just mine I got to eat the whole
pot so I just rolled with it just one of
those times you just sit quietly and you
nod yeah okay that's what you did over
there alright I'll approve that you know
anyways underrated help me gotta throw
it out there it's [ __ ] delicious so
then we [ __ ] sitting there I take my
dog out there's a little break in the
and though in the weather so I take my
dog around the block and blah blah blah
blah blah and I come back in and he is
like hey you know what why don't you
want to have a pot cookie and i was like
no i don't i got the podcast to do i got
some bills mail
[ __ ] I have to do she said come on it's
[ __ ] raining we're not going anywhere
this is a perfect day to have a pot
cookies like I don't like that [ __ ]
it gets me too [ __ ] up I feel like I'm
hallucinating I don't want to do it she
goes no these are really mild these are
really mild I know everybody out there
who [ __ ] consumes those things right
now is laughing no they're really mild
so I got fine so I [ __ ] eat this
thing right and it comes on really slow
it's mellow and oh my god I can deal
with this just sort of just be chilling
out and be relaxed and then all of a
sudden just [ __ ] to the moon Alice
right
it's like [ __ ] tripping not like
literally but it was just like you know
I closed my eyes and my feet would feel
like there were nine miles away from me
you know and that was it I took it in
the afternoon like around 4 o'clock by 5
o'clock that was it the day was over so
now here I am I got a bunch of [ __ ] to
do and I'm trying to cram this crap in
there I really know I don't like it
potheads idea of what mild is is not you
know now I'm sure I'm gonna get a bunch
of [ __ ] get a bunch of [ __ ] emails
from people going like this you want
this the TiVoed [ __ ] Asian infused
strain a weed man I don't give a [ __ ]
right I mean I was like just I was
watching TV just dying laughing at
everything that [ __ ] came on there my
wife made some corn bread with the chili
and I started doing like a cornbread
commercial you know hey guys what's
better than than a bowl of chili that's
right a nice piece of cornbread hi do
you know me of sure we all do I was just
doing that [ __ ] and I was the funniest
[ __ ] ever to me and he was looking at me
like what the [ __ ] wrong with you and
like what do you mean what's wrong with
me you [ __ ] drugged me I swear to God
you know what I think it was I think the
horror of me being around for 24 hours
with that weather she got like cabin
fever and she literally drugged me
because she was able to handle it fine
which is making me think she took less
and she was just sitting there while
TV and I'm saying all this [ __ ] that's
making me laugh and she's just sitting
there totally quiet I likey I got my
bobbin over here she was just like no no
I hear what you're saying I'm just
watching the show and I'm like how are
you that [ __ ] that comes still a
little [ __ ] up right now
24 hours later I don't know
so anyways that's why I like alcohol it
slowly comes on I know where it's going
isn't like you grab a beer and you so I
wonder what this does
what's the end no this is this is a
mellow drunk and then all of a sudden
you get like [ __ ] 20 times drunker
than you wanted to be I mean that can
start that can happen I guess with hard
stuff I just feel like the amount of
[ __ ] edibles you have to have to
start to understand what they do it's
just not [ __ ] worth it so that was my
one pot cookie for the year but anyways
I haven't had a cigar since the 8th so I
did it I'm trying to be - cigar a month
guy and I did it in January had one at
the Rose Bowl and I had one on the 8th
and then I got a whole [ __ ] month
ahead of me so rather than smoking on
the 1st you know I'm just gonna [ __ ]
chill here for like a week to ten days
and then I figure I got to I can smoke
really just taking through my whole
[ __ ] bad habit schedule they around i
I was speaking of cookies by the way I
bought two boxes of Girl Scout cookies
from this way you know it's never the
Girl Scout anymore knocking on the door
thank God thank God with all the to
catch a predators they probably got sick
of getting the door [ __ ] slammed in
their face dingdong you open the door hi
I'm selling girls got ok door [ __ ]
yelling at your dog you saw nothing
happened so anyways now that just sort
of sold by adults as far as I know so I
got to box into these [ __ ] things and
I just and finally realized the amount
of time that I've always felt like the
Girl Scouts made the cookies because
they were called Girl Scout cookies and
just somewhere maybe in the middle of
this
country somewhere around Fort Knox like
the the United League of American US
Girl Scouts has their headquarters and
they just had these giant tubs where
they just stirred up cookie batter once
a year and they got him out and after
finally thinking about it and looking at
the professional packaging I'm I'm gonna
go out on a limb here and I said I want
to say I don't think I don't think any
Girl Scouts make any of those [ __ ]
cookies
I think they [ __ ] outsourced right
it's probably made by children Central
America they sit there crying how hard
they have to work knowing they're never
going to get a bite you know and then
one of them actually steals a cookie and
there's some psychotic disciplinary
action let's take it let's google this
[ __ ] huh shall we
this is like the new segment now they'll
just you know back in the day she's just
talk now I'm actually gonna look it up
here who makes Girl Scout cookies all
right Girl Scout cookies all right Girl
Scout cookies are cookies sold by Girl
Scouts Oh Wikipedia Girl Scouts of the
USA or gs USA as one of its major
fundraisers for local Scouts units
members of the Girl Scouts of America
have been selling cookies since 1917
girls who participate can earn prizes
for their effort [ __ ] you that's my name
Alec Baldwin comes in and screams at him
all right the first cookies sales was by
a Scouting Union missile the mistletoe
troop in Oklahoma in December 1917 at
their local high school in 1922 Girl
Scout magazine the American girls
the American Girl suggested cookie sales
as a fundraiser blah blah blah blah blah
from 33 to 35 country wise organized
cookie sales grew with troops in
Philadelphia in New York City using the
cookie selling model so they're cooking
their own ones World War two they sold
calendars in 1990 the National Council
limited the Baker
providing cookies to just ABC bakeries a
division of inner inner baked foods oh
wait I skipped over some the 1953 cookie
recipes were added shortbreads peanut
butter sandwich and Thin Mints the
classic it's like the Beatles Zeppelin
and the who of cookies six types of
cookies were being sold nationwide great
a cookie sale due to the baby boom
generation they needed more the Samoa
was added in 75 all right whatever so
ABC bakers was making in the 1990s and
little brownie Baker's little priority
Baker's a division of the qiblah company
in 1998 cookie sale awards were
instituted with the 2005 trans fat
controversy the Girl Scouts moved to
make the cookies healthier and provide
nutritional information on the box in
2009 the number of Thin Mints dozy doats
and tag Tagalongs in each box was
reduced why
and lemon shallot creams became smaller
because of the increasing cost of
ingredients in transportation alright so
they try to make it with less less trans
fats here's ten weird Girl Scout cookie
facts and then I'll get off this [ __ ]
subject I dry mouth from that [ __ ]
cookie last night hey when they legalize
like pot at a federal level do you think
that they'll actually have Girl Scout
like pot cookies you know Jesus Christ
that'll be a field day well it's
happening to this country hey Shalit
drugs alright number one these cookies
are older than your grandmother that's
not weird it's not weird - you can make
the original recipe at home you can make
the original recipe of everything at
home if you know the recipe if you feel
like taking a trip back in time and
baking some boring stuff oh this must be
one of these hipster sites where they're
over everything including making [ __ ]
cookies you can try the authentic or
they actually like making the cookies
but they're anticipating being insulted
so what they do is they make fun of
themselves first so you can't
authentic original Girl Scout cookie
recipe it's not in the rest recipe but
they taste better if you dress up as a
Girl Scout when you make them oh that's
a little internet joke
only two companies make the cookies
honey booboo is banned from selling them
Thin Mints are aren't just delicious
they're mandatory I don't know what that
means
there was a cookie Queen and she's a
master sales woman oh there's a
non-sanctioned Girl Scout cookies we'd
strain of course Girl Scout cookies used
to cost less than a quarter everything
cost less there was a cookie shortage
during World War two of course not every
cookie made the grade Jesus that was
disappointing all right can I apologize
Philip wasting the last [ __ ] 15
minutes you life talking about Girl
Scout cookies did anybody watch the NHL
all-star [ __ ] three-on-three hockey
dude it was actually pretty entertaining
but not quite as exciting as I thought
it was gonna be because no one was gonna
take the body dude but it was still cool
and obviously seeing John Scott score a
couple of goals that's [ __ ] hilarious
that the NHL didn't want him in there
after all the money that they've made on
fighting and all the [ __ ] that a goon
goes through you know the fact that the
fans liked him enough to elect him into
the game right then he gets [ __ ]
traded set down to the midis and they
told him not to show up then he blogged
about it like a seventh grade chick and
everybody went dude what the [ __ ] and
then he was there and then he scored two
goals I was like a Hollywood [ __ ]
movie
hey any non hockey fans did you actually
sit down and watch the all-star game
it's everything that you would have
liked as iliyan [ __ ] goals no
fighting
nothing physical people smiling after
running into one another
was it dumbed down enough for you they
have [ __ ] hoop heads I actually only
watched the first period it's it
appeared like the first period was only
like 10 minutes long is that true or was
I under the influence of a pot cookie
but anyways all exciting knows here
exciting news for me I'm actually doing
a gig in Cheyenne Wyoming
now Wyoming is the last state that old
[ __ ] Billy red face has never
performed in and at this point I will
have performed in all [ __ ] 50 states
and that being the fact that I don't
know I have a little that OCD right that
what it is no I don't know what it is I
just like you know at first I was like
you know I'm gonna go to every baseball
stadium feta peak it immediately goes
I'm gonna go to every [ __ ] stadium
that exists you know so if I start doing
stand-up and then it become I did I've
done three states it immediately I have
to do every state and then it becomes I
have to do every continent you know
except for like Antarctica or like
places that don't want me right but
anyways I'm gonna be I'm gonna be in
Cheyenne Wyoming I'm gonna but first of
all I'm gonna be in Denver Rocky
Mountain High and please don't bring me
any [ __ ] pot cookies all right
I don't enjoy the high I don't okay I
just it's too much on the 12th and 13th
I believe the 12th and 13th is Wyoming
Denver Denver Wyoming I don't know which
one and then the 14th is Valentine's Day
and that's of course when young people
go out because they're not smart enough
to realize that that you can say I love
you on any day of the year you know it's
a great day to go out go out on like the
17th you know with the 16th or the 19th
or the 21st
don't go out right before go out after
go out after I say this every [ __ ]
year you know look at this the Super
Bowl this year is on the 7th and the
[ __ ] Valentine's Day is on the 14th
now those are two absolutely absolute
shitshow days now obviously if your own
[ __ ] football team is playing in the
Super Bowl
you know you need this you're gonna want
to watch it with a couple other fans
right however that doesn't mean that
you're gonna you go to one of those [ __ ]
show [ __ ] Super Bowl parties so like
I said as always take the [ __ ] game
let it go for a good 90 minutes then you
come in you sit down you blow through
all the commercials you'll blow through
the [ __ ] halftime show fast-forward
through all of that [ __ ] and then when
the game really starts getting down to
it you know you're caught right up
you'll catch up and like the beginning
of the the fourth quarter then you can
just kind of watch it in real time it's
[ __ ] perfect and you know blow your
whole afternoon oh sorry guys no more
pot cookies for me
and then the on the 14th same thing just
wait like two three days mmm when you
can get a [ __ ] reservation you can go
to the restaurant you want to go to and
they haven't jack the prices up through
the [ __ ] roof and then you're done
right here's a good one right cuz guys
we usually don't get [ __ ] on Valentine's
Day so I suggest don't get your wife
[ __ ] either just take her out to dinner
and [ __ ] leave it at that and if
she's like I thought you're gonna get me
something else just be like well did you
get me something else and when she's
like no you look I well I paid for
dinner
that's it and that guarantees that
you'll be in a [ __ ] awful fight on
Valentine's Day how you like that see
what I'm steering steering you towards
for the life of me bill Burke coming to
Cheyenne Civic Center 211 the [ __ ] are
you talking about
I can't be right Bill burr will perform
at the Cheyenne Civic Center in Cheyenne
Wyoming on Thursday February 11th all
right so then on the 12th I must be in
Denver is that right
Jesus Christ bill how do you know why
don't you [ __ ] know your own goddamn
schedule Denver Ida go skiing when I'm
out there you know I skied once every 10
years I really should take a lesson go
that that is just the blow you [ __ ] yeah
the 12th all right so the 11th Thursday
I'm in Wyoming and February 12th I'm in
Denver oh that's how it is very nice
so there you go the Cheyenne Civic
Center you know they always have [ __ ]
rodeos and [ __ ] they'd all right what
goes on there Toby Keith Cheyenne Civic
Center Civic Santa speed up some old ABA
building
damages Jesus Christ look at Cheyenne
this looks like a [ __ ] opera plays
they're an opera bill and orchestra the
Cheyenne Civic Center Hey
going to Cheyenne Wyoming what are some
of the great things that happened in
Wyoming over the years huh
only thing you always hear is bad stuff
isn't that place with a will they tied
that poor kid because he was gay to the
fence until he died this isn't good they
don't have any sports tapes the [ __ ] am
I going to Wyoming for Wyoming this is
where like Ted Turner can ride his horse
all over the place and be like I own
that I own that too get off of there or
I'll take you out of your basic cable
package take Mike my [ __ ] TV out of
here don't ever start any [ __ ] with Ted
Turner in Wyoming all right because he's
gonna come and arrest you and then he's
gonna be the judge and he's gonna throw
you in Geo it's the whole [ __ ] state
does he I believe he does right I don't
know anyways let's get to the [ __ ]
reach here for this week Oh Billy all
over the place all right what do we got
here the first read oh look who's back
everybody sharise berries must be a clam
day coming up oh yes it is Valentine's
Day is next week finding the right gift
can be tricky tell a personal story
relating to Valentine's Day well you
know I think it's [ __ ] you know I
always hated it when I was [ __ ]
younger I think everything's overpriced
and everybody just sits there looking
around at everybody you know and then
somebody gets proposed to
like oh my god and then you know even if
you already proposed to the one you're
with there's still kind of [ __ ]
jealous and sad you know they do just
sit there splitting a dessert that's the
part I hate the most just sitting there
splitting dessert because that means
I've wanted to leave for at least an
hour in ten minutes I just feel like
you're distant tonight oh he's an
example of the story why you give
Valentine's Day gifts
getting the wrong gift getting the right
gift horror stories of waiting until the
last minute
etc I don't think you should get him a
gift
I don't you should get him anything more
than sharise berries the [ __ ] are they
getting you where is the copy for what
the lay is gonna get the guide this is
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] this just this
whole holidays completely [ __ ] sexist
and I you know I'd like to hear more
over a little chatter from the [ __ ]
feminist ladies there about this you
know why are you taking me out why don't
I take you out every other year and then
I get you a gift come on ladies let's
have an even playing field right alright
you want to give something unique that
you love but you don't to spend a
zillion dollars
you know you want to say hey I'm really
like you you know I really like you but
I'm not quite in love with you yet but
I'd like you to continue [ __ ] me what
would be a perfect gift
Sherri's berries freshly dripped
strawberries from sharri's berries
starting at only $19.99 it's over 40%
savings that's less than a hooker and if
you don't want if you really want hero
status you can double the berries for
just 10 bucks just go to berries calm
click on the microphone and type in my
code be URR these strawberries are
picked at the peak of freshness no
they're not they never are they [ __ ]
get yanked and then they throw them and
they ripen on the truck they ripe
they're all fruit ripens on the [ __ ]
truck without the nutrients from the
vine to ensure the best gift experience
they're huge and dipped in white milk
and dark chocolatey goodness topped with
chocolate chips chopped nuts and
decorative swizzle delivery is always
guaranteed
Oh we'll get them there we just don't
know when here's the only way to get
these amazing valid this amazing
Valentine's Day deal juicy huge and
freshly dipped strawberries starting at
just $19.99 or double the berries you
[ __ ] [ __ ] for $10 more visit berries
dot-com please spell out the word
berries B e RR IES dot-com click on the
microphone on the in the top right hand
corner and type in Barbie you are our
go-to berries comm click on the
microphone and enter my code today B you
are R alright ProFlowers look who's here
everybody a little candy and flowers you
gotta buy an old school outfit too a
little Derby 3-piece vest three-piece
suit I should say with the vest little
pocket watch
alright blow pro flowers sometimes
parentheses okay
all the time it's hard for us guys to
say what we feel what if there was a
gift that said said it for you Jesus see
how sexist this [ __ ] is you're too
[ __ ] dumb to say what you're thinking
why don't we handle it while the bunch
of [ __ ] ly ripped out of the ground
imagine a gift that was thoughtful easy
and she'd love and that set your message
perfectly all in one is your beautiful
flowers they're beautiful like you I
call that a win on Valentine's Day tell
a personal story relating to Valentine's
Day well I always thought it was [ __ ]
[ __ ] I always thought it was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] holiday you know you
pay way too much money and then halfway
through some other woman gets proposed
to it even if you already proposed to
your woman she's still looking over
there like I don't feel like I'm the
[ __ ] Queen of the ball they really
like these personal stories example why
you give Valentine's Day gifts getting
the wrong gift Jesus the same people
write this [ __ ] Pro flowers are the
flower pros that make Valentines Day
easy trust ProFlowers and get this year
done right Pro flowers is offering my
listeners plus any other podcast they
advertise on 100 blooms
of love plus a free glass vase for just
$19.99 plus this week only you'll get
free chocolates for when you order 4 by
Friday ah they're cut into Sheree's
Berry's turf there's gonna be a [ __ ]
war go to proflowers.com and use my coat
bar but you are our ProFlowers is quick
and easy and delivers for valentine's
day deliveries for Valentine's Day has
guaranteed ProFlowers I guarantee the
last 7 days or your money back it's a
no-brainer here's the only way to get
amazing Valentine's the amazing
Valentine's Day deal including the free
chocolates go to proflowers.com click on
the blue microphone in the top corner
type in bar that's proflowers.com click
on the microphone and type in my code
bar you must order by Friday at midnight
in order to get this deal wow that's
gonna be an issue huh they cutting right
into Sherry's berries Sherry's [ __ ]
berries well there's only one more here
so I might as well plow through it no no
there's two more all right we'll split
it up we'll split it you know I was
actually debating watching the Super
Bowl by myself and doing a little bit of
commentating during the game you guys
seem to enjoy that maybe I'll do
commentating during the shittiest most
boring parts but then I'd have to sit
and watch it like whoever's opening and
I know stings playing the halftime show
as much as I want to go see him and and
Vinnie Colaiuta is on my bucket list
like that's not the right band by
halftime at the Super Bowl huh every
breath you take every move you make he's
gonna have to go more up-tempo [ __ ] what
do you think Sting's gonna play from his
repertoire huh anything off 10 summer
tails but that's not the queen of my
heart no that's not the shape of my
heart I can't play that song by oh now
now but double double bow now now now
now what sounds a bold Dogo Danko
the [ __ ] song was that then that was
a song about the brothers the one that
he was a coward none of that is gonna
play well he'll probably place
synchronicity right you had a football
game that's stadium Rock to just sit
there go all right bunch of old baby
boomers singing along a bunch of kids
going that's not dubstep dad you I want
to fast-forward through all that [ __ ]
yeah I'm thinking about maybe
commentating on some of that stuff I
just do like maybe I'll just do like
three minutes of the game you know cuz I
think it'll get boring after a while you
know at least if I'm gonna get bored of
myself I would think that you guys would
get bored no all right let's plow
through here so I don't have any booze
in the fridge so I'm just I guess the
month of I sort of half-assed committed
to this like not boozing is that a bad
thing
[ __ ] is the other oh there it is sorry
talked about everything pot cookie
rating out here shine oh I haven't been
on the [ __ ] Road in weeks so I might
be doing wink wink oh I am doing a show
this week that's right I'm doing the
deed el rey del rey at the El Rey oh
Jesus a night of comedy and Rock Dean
Del Rey's 50th birthday party he's going
to have you know he's going to have Joe
Rogan Chris D'Elia myself I know there's
a couple other comics red bands gonna be
down there and I want to say I want to
say there's maybe one other comic and
then after that Dean Del Rey is gonna
front a band that will include the likes
of Rudy Sarzo
Dave Kushner Dave Lombardo Tracy guns
Gilby Clarke all these rock stars and
he's going to sing the entire highway to
hell album and old Billy red face might
sit in for a song or two but it's going
to be a great night you can get tickets
at golden voice calm and also
I might be doing a a surprise show
somewhere locally because I got to run
my hour so when I go to Cheyenne Wyoming
when I get out there I want to make sure
they going to be on my game I don't want
people in the crowd being like what the
[ __ ] man you made us wait to be number
50 for that [ __ ] walking around
there John Denver [ __ ] cheap coats
right got the Sheep lining Rocky
Mountain High Colorado but we don't talk
like that
we'll talk like this that's what Wyoming
is all about I'm going to the Capitol
men do they have open carry in Wyoming
you know I made such a big deal about
open carry in Texas and turns out that
they've had it in Oklahoma for years and
there hasn't been a [ __ ] problem so
that's kind of a non-story and then a I
think that kind of adds to the touristy
vibe of going to Texas and seeing people
walking around with holsters you know
maybe you can see say have somebody have
a [ __ ] shootout over like a parking
parking space a duel right draw yeah
worst case scenario just a bunch of
people that I don't know die which is
considering with global warming and
overpopulation I think it's a good thing
I think they should have open carry
they should have everywhere everybody
strapped it would probably actually end
up being safer when you think about it
because I know like New York City for as
much as everybody talks about how
dangerous it was I just found on the on
the subways where where all of a sudden
you were riding in the car would [ __ ]
everybody it's all mixed up there was a
certain level of heightened courtesy
because you didn't want to have a
[ __ ] problem you know it's the subway
it's New York City you could get mugged
you could get the [ __ ] kicked out of you
so people [ __ ] mind at that business
so I think if you had a whole state of
everybody walking around with a gun on
their hip you know somebody cuts you off
in traffic you know yeah you know yeah I
could yell you [ __ ] [ __ ] but if
you start shooting at me yeah that's
okay go ahead buddy I mean I have a gun
too but you know what if I miss and you
don't
by all means go in front of me you know
like if somebody's being weird to you
and you're one of those ATMs that's on
the outside of a building yeah it's a
very nervous moment for you but if
you're in your car and that same person
cut you off you're yeah you're all tough
in your car which can lead to road rage
now if you know that that guy is a gun
he could just simply you know pointed
out the side of his car just shoot in
the general direction of your car you
figure at the very least he's got to hit
the radiator right you have that steam
coming up like in every [ __ ] movie
just right you're probably going to mind
your [ __ ] business maybe that's the
secret to ending all wars everybody's
strapped and you have the gun out you
just walk in and every time you just
walk you just the guns already pointed
at somebody how you doing I'm doing good
how are you by right yeah keep the
conversation short and sweet I think I
just solved all our all of our problems
all right everybody's strapped with a
gloated gun out pointed at somebody
safety off cause you'd be more relaxed
you know all they couldn't have safety
off because then when people fell asleep
you know it's like falling asleep while
you know smoking you can let your bed on
fire you might squeeze off a round which
doesn't even make sense right because
you got to put pressure on it unless you
have in one of those dreams you know you
have every one of those dreams where
you're falling or somebody just gives
you a leg sweep sweep your leg for
whatever reason and you have to get
[ __ ] tensed up maybe then you shoot
yourself in the foot I bet podiatrist to
be off that bet they're all for
open-carry
you know the foot doctors all right you
want me to do with some reeds for this
week here let's get into it
what are we come on bill for God's sakes
I was on the right one to begin with
oh hey by the way does anybody know like
when a [ __ ] for whatever reason you
download an album off of iTunes and then
for whatever reason it just sort of
disappears off of your phone and then
[ __ ] reappears because you haven't
hooked it up to the computer you know
what I mean with your phone and that
makes it legitimately on your phone
rather than just going through the air
or whatever the [ __ ] going on right
you know cuz you got the Wi-Fi on and
then the Wi-Fi shuts off and then the
album disappears so then you're old like
me so you download it again and then you
got that album and then the first one
comes back and now you got doubles how
do you get rid of the other one I've
gone into my iTunes and I've gone to
delete it but on my phone it's still in
doubles I don't know how to do it so the
song ends and then it replays again it
plays everything twice that happened me
with Van Halen 1984 and that nas album
Illmatic and as much as I love both of
those albums I don't need both songs to
play twice how do I get rid of the other
one if anybody can tell me I would
really appreciate it all right
okay Kanye situation hey Bill
red-blooded American male here who heard
about the Kanye situation and was scared
shitless
I'm not going to disclose whether or not
I enjoy what he was accused of enjoying
parentheses if you don't know the story
his ex Amber Rose implied on Twitter
that he enjoyed a finger in his ass
actually it was fingers plural yeah I
didn't hear about this [ __ ] story and
it made me feel good as a human being
that I was somehow out of the loop of
this [ __ ] noose he said this scared
me because it doesn't matter what you're
into if an ex says [ __ ] like that you're
going to get branded sir you sound like
your ex put a vase in your ass anyways
he goes it's how urban myths about
gerbils get started unless you're
fearless Jim Norton and you can say
something like that with the smile on
your face on the Airways it's a pretty
tough situation to be it how does a man
like Kanye deal with that I don't know
I I when I started to read it but I
don't it just I don't if it is true I
don't give a [ __ ] it's really none of my
business before I could tell from the
article he was talking [ __ ] about her
now had if she had half her hand up his
[ __ ] ass at some point it's probably
not a smart idea if he's sensitive about
that part of his sexuality to be talking
[ __ ] right
which makes me kind of believe him then
it didn't happen because you figure if
she had that over him if she was walking
around with him like a sock puppet right
that he wouldn't go around talking [ __ ]
about her I don't know I got to be
honest it's one of those things that I I
legitimately feel is none of my [ __ ]
business and whether it's true or not
doesn't make me look at Kanye one way or
the other I mean I don't give a [ __ ] I
give a [ __ ] what the guy does and I also
think I don't think you walk around
talking [ __ ] about someone you used to
go out with didn't work out [ __ ] grow
up you're already married you found
somebody else leave him alone right I
don't look I don't know what happened
but all I know he was if it's true that
he was talking [ __ ] about her I probably
should stop saying talking [ __ ] when
we're talking about a finger up your ass
you know I haven't said all that it's
[ __ ] hilarious I you know I would
think that there's a lot of rival
rappers right now trying to write down
words that rhyme with the phrase fingers
up your ass lingers in the class with
fingers up your ass I'm sorry I don't
know but there's got to be something
that they're coming up with that's an
easy one - if I was if I was a rapper
and somebody said that my ex put fingers
up my ass how all I would be thinkers
like god damn it why didn't she say
rectum
at least make it difficult to rhyme
something rectum check them you check
them fingers up your rectum now fingers
check them all clean going up your
rectum sorry
anyways classes I like that no that's a
hundred percent on him what about her
with this stinky fingers now Jesus
Christ you got to go with the fist bump
now when you go within two F when you
run into amber give her the old elbow
want to stay away from that get a [ __ ]
tetanus shot
funny she shook her hand and then all of
a sudden you just started [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] about yourself the way
Kanye does
alright classes in high school
hello you orangutan lookin [ __ ]
I guaranteed that this guy is the
ugliest [ __ ] I really find that
people people who trash the way I look
the most especially on Twitter never
have like there never have their picture
I don't look like an orangutan do I
they're [ __ ] older they look like old
people in a housecoat I am a senior in
high school yeah like a kid oh you're
probably a teen at this point you punk
and this may seem childish to talk about
but I've been thinking about dropping
one of my classes
this class is music theory ap and I'm a
straight B student student so I'm no
genius I talked to my teacher and
guidance counselor who both said it was
fine to drop it music theory being a
unique class
what was that appendix right there at
the end there that didn't make that was
all part of that sentence anyways
recently I came into school thinking
that was this [ __ ] like I came into
school thinking that this [ __ ] was over
and I wouldn't have to take the class
anymore only to have the assistant
principal of my school tell me that I
would not be able to drop at that this
point I'm frustrated because I'm very
unhappy in the class
and the only ones separating me from
dropping the class is my prick of an
assistant principal should I sack up and
finish the rest of the year or should I
stand up from my case and become a
stubborn prick in the process the class
gives me anxiety and I'm not really into
music anymore I'm thinking about picking
up a second English class if the
principal doesn't let me drop the class
I would probably end up skipping it
every day because I hate the class that
[ __ ] much am I in the wrong any
advice would be great bill thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself oh when I was a kid when
you went to high school you couldn't
drop classes that happened in college
you're a senior it's February
don't you get out in like the middle of
May
and if you transfer do you have to make
up the first two semesters or whatever
the [ __ ] it is September October
November and December and January worth
of [ __ ] and your second English class I
just tough it out it's music theory I
mean that sounds boring as [ __ ]
but whatever just tough it out I'd yeah
that's what I would do I mean I mean I
would rather tuck up tough but maybe
just speak my about myself personally
but I rather tough out music theory than
dad take another [ __ ] English class
but that's me yeah dude just [ __ ]
tough it out what's it giving you exam
using Theory teacher it's not like
they're gonna be like it's like the
football coach is teaching it is he yeah
[ __ ] it tough it out that seems like a
class that even if you just halfway pay
attention you can at least get a C right
I don't know dude this [ __ ] [ __ ]
hangover from this goddamn cookie I mean
I fell asleep last night at like 6
o'clock I slept for like 12 [ __ ]
hours I'm still exhausted all right
being stung by [ __ ] hey Billy big
freckle balls
I love it you guys think I Sun my nuts
your last podcast touched on being stung
by spiders and [ __ ] and you touched on
stingrays those [ __ ] that killed Steve
Irving I know no no no no no no no he
[ __ ] with them and the thing felt like
it had to defend itself all right I'll
tell you right now the the rejoicing
that Wildlife did overall when the
Crocodile Hunter got killed I mean the
level of stress that he brought every
animal that he came into contact with
all see he's hunching up he doesn't like
that the thing isn't fear for its
[ __ ] life and you're going up and
you're [ __ ] with the things you can
you know and your little [ __ ] booty
shorts anyways he goes I'm Canadian and
I spent five minutes in an American
ocean and was stung by a stingray well
all of your oceans are American too you
live in North America we're all
Americans but I guess once you say
you're Canadian
I'm United okay I'm a Canadian I spent
five minutes in an American ocean was
stung by a stingray it felt like a hot
nail being driven through my foot and
the pain went up and up for hours was
the most painful thing I've ever
experienced let that be a lesson to all
the listeners that stingrays are not
something to be [ __ ] with nothing can
describe that pain it was insane
love the podcast [ __ ] you in Boston
because they would so [ __ ] always
because they went so [ __ ] always yeah
well you know this is the thing we're
not supposed to be in the ocean okay I'm
gonna say that again we're not supposed
to be in the ocean I can't breathe in
there we can't see what's beneath us
we're completely vulnerable when we go
in there we're not supposed to be in
there that stingray has evolved to [ __ ]
up things that belong in the ocean all
of which are way bigger and way faster
generally speaking some giant fish goes
to [ __ ] killed a stingray
it's got to have enough juice in it
shank to make a shark go away I would
think so yeah you come walking in you
[ __ ] pink feet come walking in there
if you white right you go in there and
you did just yeah it's over
so prom surprise they don't got enough
juice to kill you because I know Steve
Irving what happened him is he got
stabbed in the [ __ ] in it I think it
punctured his heart what are the odds of
that I wonder what his [ __ ] last
thoughts were he's [ __ ] out really
[ __ ] stingray what was he just taking
ow let me just pull this out I'm sure
that befell enough oh that's artery
blood all right
love the podcast kill [ __ ] you see you
know it's funny somebody in Austria is
gonna be offended that I'm actually
[ __ ] talking like they haven't
thought about this [ __ ] I don't like ten
years ago what is the statute of
limitations when you deliberately go and
[ __ ] with a stingray and get killed by
that it's that you can't keep talking
about it alright beer drinking contests
advice dear Billy beer bomb I'm a big
fan man I listened to your podcast for a
couple of years now and I had the chance
to see you versi and blodnik at the
Chicago theater great show so I've been
roped into a beard beer drinking
Olympics parentheses for charity by a
buddy of mine and being that I'm an old
[ __ ] not quite what you are I'm 38 I was
wondering if you have advice in terms of
longevity backstory on me I'm a Canadian
I'm a Canadian pocket square wearing
halfs van I know [ __ ] me right I don't
give a [ __ ] as long as you have a sense
of humor about yourself
that can really hammer them back beer is
my first choice when I drink as I assume
as yours what would you do to get ready
for something like this thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself well you got it I would
think aren't there going to be different
events you know there's got to be
drinking beer there's got to be drinking
hard stuff is it all just going to be
beer drinking
wait a second I was wondering you have
any advice in terms of longevity all
right as far I thought you meant how do
I to live long you mean how to hang in
there well if it's a beer-drinking
contest and I would just drink hard
stuff leading up to it you know a couple
of beers didn't have like your shots too
you know I don't know build up your
tolerance this doesn't seem like this is
a responsible thing for me to be telling
you to do I would be I would just go
there and have a good time that's what I
would do and I wouldn't try to win a
medal you don't want to be the guy that
wins that the guy wins that's gonna have
like [ __ ] rosacea on the side of his
face from booze and you know if it's
gonna look like [ __ ] WC Fields you
don't wanna be the guy that can win that
contest I would say just go there have a
good time you know and stop short of
being the guy that [ __ ] pukes all
over everybody that would be my advice
all right let me do the last Reed's here
really quickly and then I'll do the last
question there's a [ __ ] trying to
shake off this goddamn yawning from that
[ __ ] cookie I'm like overtired here
all right okay have you guys been
watching any of the Super Bowl pregame
why would you are they doing the old man
versus the young man these Panthers have
the [ __ ] Carolina
the thing about cam booting is this guy
is one of those rare talents that just
can hurt you on every level you cover
his receivers no problem this guy's
gonna run it
you're gonna rush this guy you can't
bring him down with just what guy you're
gonna stand there and stare at him he's
gonna pick you apart I'll tell you right
now I would not want to have this job is
being a coach over these Denver Broncos
eclipse Mike why do you think you're
gonna do well I think the key to the
game is Denver has to get the ball and
they have to score early they gotta
score often their best hope to control
Cam Newton is to take the Panthers out
of their game plan if they're playing
catch-up all night you know with that
Denver defense and Dan
no don't take you know I know Peyton
Manning's older but this is still Peyton
Manning okay just last game I'll tell
you right now he's a competitor he's
gonna get out there and although the
Panthers have a good defense they still
are a young defensive unit okay and then
you watch that to come into play
especially after they make their
halftime adjustments is that about it
something like that they're gonna try to
exploit the thieves what about special
teams what about Peyton Manning's wife
taking HGH what are the odds of that
Dollar Shave Club everyone lots of
players will be sporting playoff beards
now that the post seasons here can you
imagine if Giselle was getting [ __ ]
HGH sent to the house I'm sure that
story would just disappear after a
couple of moments leave that to the pros
kick off your year the right way with a
fresh blade shave that's why me and when
millions of others have joined the
dollarshaveclub.com revolution Dollar
Shave Club knows that the key to getting
an amazing shave is simple one use a
fresh Dollar Shave Club blade to use
their doctor copies easy that's it
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
razors right to my door for a third of
the price of those greedy mega razor
corporations that means listeners who
switched now can afford the luxury of
shaving with the fresh blade anytime and
save hundreds this year and when you
combine that fresh blade with their
doctor copies easy it just glides
it's unimaginably smooth I'm telling you
it's not your average shave for them it
won't dry out your skin the all-natural
ingredients leave your skin feeling soft
smooth and moisturized after every shave
take it from me use a fresh Dollar Shave
Club blade with dr. can have easy shave
butter if you want the most gentle shape
imaginable join della shape Club calm
slash bar today
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash bar
alright stamps calm everyone you know
what sometimes it feel like sometimes it
feels like there's just not enough hours
in the day even when you work even when
you're working past the 9:00 to 5:00
that doesn't make sense so if you're
still making time-consuming trips to the
PO
office you need a better way you stamps
combo stamps calm gets postage get the
post that you need the instant you need
it by and print official US postage for
any letter and package from your
computer or a printer it's quick and
easy you'll save money with stamps calm
- it's just a fraction of the cost of
one of those expensive postage meters
plus you'll get special postage
discounts you can't even find at the
post office I use stamps calm to send
out all my posters whatever I'm pouring
myself up right now sign up for stamps
calm and use my last name Barbie you are
are for this special offer for week
trial plus the $110 bonus offer that
includes postage at a digital scale get
started with stance calm today today
today within minutes you'll be printing
postage right from your desk go to
Stan's car before you do anything else
took on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in / b you are r that
stamps.com
enter ber alrighty mercifully it has
ended all right let's get back to got
one more read here and then I got a wrap
this [ __ ] up because time for me to go
alright dating in the workplace
aka no geez Billy [ __ ] boy burp oh hey
by the way I finished the second season
of top boy I highly highly recommend it
alright there's a lady in my workplace
that I have a huge crush on but I [ __ ]
everything up by drunkenly telling her
best friend at a company holiday party
that I had a crush on on her I say
[ __ ] up because I know how females
communicate I might as well have just
walked up to the girl I had a crush on
and told her I know from a past job that
dating in the workplace [ __ ] everything
else up at work had told myself I'd
never do it again but for some reason my
brain couldn't say no to this girl
anyway I know this girl knows I like her
from her best friend and it made our
work dynamic awkward just because when
we interact now both of us feel like we
have to fulfill some sort of role well
you should just walked up to it says hey
I got a little drunk I said some things
to your girlfriend that you know I
should have said to you
now I can't say that that's too forward
well the office just makes it creepy you
can't lead on anything as you're talking
to her you might as well just be
standing there rubbing your balls ah
yeah it's a situation one day I said
[ __ ] it and half asked her out to an art
museum but she had friends in town said
she couldn't what pisses me off is that
I used to hang out with my coworkers and
this girl every now and then
now no one invites me to hang out when
they do background on the company it's
under a hundred people and we're all in
our 20s for the most part what's the
best way to pursue this girl in this
situation and how do I mentally handle
the fact that it's affected my ability
to hang out with my coworker
my other co-workers I really want
closure to this thing whether it be a
date whether I date her or she tells me
she's not interested I don't care at
this point I really don't like the
tension at work thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah which says to me you don't
really even like this girl Mike I just
want to ask her out get rid of the
tension because she says yes so she says
no I'd really don't give a [ __ ] at this
moment this is what you do this is what
you do sir you just just [ __ ] blow it
off just blow it off you don't give a
[ __ ] just act normal around her all
right that she'll be going like oh he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and then she'll
probably end up being interested in you
because that's how they [ __ ] work all
right
don't don't hang out with the people you
work with [ __ ] someone you don't work
with you need to create a social circle
outside of work the people at work
should be the people you see Monday
through Friday okay and then once Friday
see you later guys take it easy what are
you doing I'm getting the [ __ ] away from
you all right then you go out you can do
your [ __ ] black tar heroin or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do and
then there's no awkwardness at the
copier all right you already said you
[ __ ] somebody that you work with
before and how that made your last job
awkward yet here you go again and for
some reason you're not even in a
relationship yet and it's already
[ __ ] up your coat you're you sure
your interaction with your co-workers
yet you want to pursue this thing dude I
would just let it go
just let it go and listen if you want to
[ __ ] somebody at work don't try and [ __ ]
him all right just come in with a big
smile on your face on Monday and have
you know nobody knows what the [ __ ] you
did and they're all hanging out with
each other they're all gossiping with
each other and eventually they're gonna
be gossiping about you eh I wonder what
he does what's up with his exciting life
you know and you're coming in looking
like you're out there banging away and
[ __ ] having a great time going out in
the town eventually one of these broads
is gonna be [ __ ] interested enough and
then you know what your dumb ass is
gonna [ __ ] her and then it's gonna be
awkward again can't do it dude you got
it you got to have a [ __ ] your social
sir you are [ __ ] and you're drinking
and all that has to be outside of work
unless it's a guy okay it cannot be
cannot [ __ ] hang with women that you
work with you can't do it cuz eventually
your dicks gonna make you say something
stupid something's gonna happen well
that's gonna get in the [ __ ] way and
it's just gonna be a big be a big
goddamn problem same thing don't hang
out with your boss either hang out with
somebody that's on your [ __ ] level
and even then do it I wouldn't I
wouldn't hang out you don't hang out
with people you work with
you know something always ends up
happening maybe you do something dumb
and then your buddy can't keep his
[ __ ] mouth shut you know and then it
gets to somebody and then that you're up
for your your review you don't get as
much money you get passed over it's
[ __ ] stupid you were in your 20s you
got to make a you're gonna make a bunch
of [ __ ] mistakes so don't do it with
the people you work with all right have
I said that enough times all right
having said that you want to be my Super
Bowl pick I actually like the Broncos
with the points if they're getting six
and don't listen to me because I don't
know anything about the Broncos coach
but I know Bill Belichick with Peyton
Manning and that defense could figure
out a way to beat the Carolina Panthers
and I know a lot of you guys are
thinking well that defense and that
coach and Peyton Manning just beat your
Patriots and Bill Belichick it's like
well he didn't have the team you know my
only concern is that Denver's defense
isn't as
as it looked against the Patriots
because we had that Swiss cheese [ __ ]
offensive line we had injuries all that
year and Carolina looks really healthy
their offensive line looks really
healthy so I don't know I think that
[ __ ] that I actually said earlier
where I was making fun of those analysis
those analysts is actually what I think
Denver better hope that when the toss
and I would say take the ball rather
than deferring it and hopefully you
march down the field score seven give
them a three and out I think I literally
think that they need to score again go
up ten nothing this is my keys to the
game Denver win the toss they need to go
out there and somehow get it done and
choose heads if it's going to be heads
tails if it's going to be tails then
they got to take the [ __ ] ball Ram it
down their [ __ ] throats
yeah just obvious [ __ ] nice
time-consuming Drive and establish the
run
I think Peyton could do alright against
their defense if they if they you know
if he has the [ __ ] time see there's
no way to say really bill what if he
doesn't have the time does that make it
more difficult this is really hard this
is really it's really hard to say
something that isn't cliched my concern
is a Broncos fan is that the Panthers
get the ball they march right down the
field and they score because
what's-his-face Peyton Manning is gloom
and doom guy that guy gets that look on
his face Peyton faces what me and my
family used to call it where he just he
just purses his lips and he starts
looking downfield shaking his head as he
takes his [ __ ] chinstrap off after
yet another three and out that's that
that's them the headspace Panthers want
to get him in if he gets into that he
gets into that and why isn't everybody
as good as me mindset it's [ __ ] over
so in order to keep him happy I'd say
that they got a scorer I'm back to that
again Jesus maybe I'll come up with
something on Thursday there you go
everybody
buh-buh-buh-buh - a boat oh I take the
Broncos in the points I take six points
[ __ ] it cuz every [ __ ] out that's gonna
take the Panthers every [ __ ] out there
is gonna do the Panthers are gonna
[ __ ] destroy them that's when you
want to go the other way because
whatever that means that every [ __ ]
[ __ ] that out there it's gonna put money
on the Panthers which means the line
will keep going up cuz Vegas is one
again who's gonna want to get money on
both sides of the ball
thank you Bill like we didn't know that
oh [ __ ] you I'll talk to you guys on
Thursday go [ __ ] yourselves and don't
[ __ ] anybody you work with